cette procédure de sanction ouverte
contre ert france l'a été suite à la
diffusion d'un sujet en avril 2019
dans ce sujet il est fait état de
déclarations d'un général russe à propos
de la syrie pour en parler je vous
propose d'aller à la rencontre de jérôme
bonnet rédacteur en chef de rtl france
la question est de savoir si les propos
polémiques d'un haut dignitaire
militaires russes représentent de
l'intérêt pour le public
pour moi la réponse est oui à condition
que les pays qui le met en cause est
également voix au chapitre et puisse
répondre ce qui est le cas dans ce sujet
là on est vraiment dans la pratique la
plus élémentaires du journalisme
effectivement il y à une polémique donc
on explique d'où elle vient qu'elles
font les accusations portées et puis les
mises en cause peuvent répondre
et après à notre audience de se faire
son opinion une audience publique va
donc avoir lieu ce mercredi 26 février
audience au cours de laquelle rt france
va être entendues par le csa et on verra
si le conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel
suivi l'avis du rapporteur indépendant
qui a préconisé de ne pas sanctionner
notre média
réponse dans les toutes prochaines
heures